en france le sort des enfants et leurs
conditions de vie sont dans l'ensemble
bien supérieur à la situation des
millions de mines infrarouge les vulkins
encore de nombreux sujets d'inquiétude
pour les associations des droits de
l'enfant des efforts restent à faire
notamment l'amélioration de l'accueil et
de la protection des mineurs étrangers
isolés ces adolescents viennent en
france pour obtenir le statut de réfugié
mais trop peu de structures comme ce
centre en région parisienne existent
pour leur prise en charge
autre point noir en france le droit de
l'enfant à connaître ses origines n'est
pas toujours respectée en cas
d'accouchement sous x
ce qui n'est pas en conformité avec la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
principal sujet de préoccupation la
maltraitance des mines près de 80 mille
petits français seraient en danger selon
les associations de protection louise
est une société kds moins en moins d'y
être social qu'elle de moins en moins de
sociabilité et on le sait que ça
provoque énormément de de problèmes dans
les familles la montée notamment des
familles monoparentales alors qu'elles
sont de plus en plus isolé en train une
progression du nombre d'enfants risquent
dans cette société
d'autres questions comme la pratique en
matière d'arrestation et de détention
des mineurs ou encore la législation sur
l'apprentissage inquiète aussi les
associations tous ces enfants ont donc
désormais une autorité indépendante
chargée de défendre leurs droits
claire brisset a déjà indiqué de son
côté ses priorités les mineurs en prison
la lutte contre les réseaux pédophiles
sur internet et l'accueil des enfants à
l'hôpital